[Music]
okay so I told you at the beginning of
my first lightning talk or at night talk
that if you're interested in any of this
stuff you can follow me on twitter at
don't use this code let me show you why
that's my twitter handle so a couple
years ago I got it kind of got tired of
the explicit self in Python where you
have to type self as the first argument
for every instance method so I said
could you do something like this you
could have like an underscore variable
that gets injected into the function you
can make it an instance method then you
never have to write that self as that
first argument and I called it implicit
self and it turns out this is very easy
to do in Python as long as you have C
types or C FFI you can find the
structure of the Python method you can
take things that are supposed to be
read-only and make them read right like
the closure you can rewrite the bytecode
to turn if you saw my talk earlier today
to turn what was originally a low global
into a low dear F and you can make just
just work and so that was pretty easy to
do and with many of these hacks they
become boring the moment you accomplish
them so I started to look for something
that was harder now it's an interesting
puzzle in general what you can do to
manipulate a running Python interpreter
I have a number of different ways to
change the Python interpreter by
importing modules and this is actually
something that can be useful in practice
because many of us use tools that rely
on sandboxes are written in Python and
many of us may rely on Python versions
that have some security mechanisms like
only allowing signed code to run and the
moment you can manipulate your Python
interpreter you can just turn off those
mechanisms this is one example this
shows you why any sandboxing tool that
includes the use of C that allows the
use of C FF IRC types is trivial to
break because the moment you can get a
pointer to some part of the memory for
the Python interpreter you can start
fiddling bits and change the way the
Python interpreter works what I want to
show you is that this is actually even
easier to do even in less even in cases
where you don't have the ability to get
access to memory through something like
C types your c FF I because if you're on
Linux it turns out on Linux
there is a proc file system and proc
file system has the ability to look at
two things for the current running
process inside proc self you have two
files one called maps that gives you all
the memory
that process has loaded and the memory
itself so here's a fairly simple Python
script that loads up for itself all the
memory that it's loaded traverses
through that memory to find a specific
object namely this sentinel value finds
that central value writes directly to
memory without using c types or CF fi or
anything but simple reading and writing
of files and changes X into y we think
that strings are immutable in python
well if you have raw memory access you
can make anything that should be
immutable immutable this was pretty
boring once I finished figuring out how
to do this it's a very simple technique
but it's a generalizable technique
across any language you can always get
access to raw memory in any language on
Linux where you have a proc file system
what I want to show you is the most
sophisticated Python hack I have ever
seen and the most probably hack you will
ever see in your entire life unless the
person who came up with it comes up with
something Wilder because this is nothing
compared to what you can really do it is
not my own work it is the work of a
friend of mine named Joe Jeff Nick and
if you want to follow me on twitter
follow him first because this kid is
amazing I'll give you a premise for this
when I was doing my implicit self one of
the things that I do is I inject this
self variable into the closure for the
function and then swap a load global
into a load D ref so that this variable
gets picked up from the closure that
turns out to be very simple and a while
back Joe wanted to yeah it hit a simple
question which is how do you make
closures mutable because currently the
closures are immutable and using C types
I was able to find the flag that makes
the closures immutable and flip that if
you take that out what can you do well
it turns out with a little bit of
craziness in terms of how you construct
a Python function object you can create
a Python function object that has
corrupted bike code that allows you to
write into the closure and this is my
approach he hasn't even better an even
better approach for this that works both
in C Python and in pi PI but this is not
the actual hack I I know of projects in
the world that require that required
that the Python interpreter be
impossible to mutate in order to enforce
certain security mechanisms on that
Python interpreter certain sandboxing
mechanisms and if you take out CF if I
take out C types take out PI 132 and
don't run it on Linux
none of these techniques work except we
were able to find one that
I was thinking well how do you usually
do things like corrupt memory you find
an array access that you're not supposed
an air access outbound checking so I
thought let's go to the Python
interpreter and see if we can find one
of those well it turns out when a Python
interpreter
stores a local variable it does this
thing called set local and set local is
a macro that uses get local and get
local does an array access but doesn't
check the bounds so every time PI that
the Python interpreter has a byte code
that stores a local variable it does an
array access with no bounds checking so
if you can figure out a way to corrupt
that index you can write arbitrarily a
memory and there is no way for anybody
to block this without making substantial
significant changes the Python
interpreter far beyond what could be
done easily Joe found a way to actually
use this and what I'm gonna show you is
just off the wall wild he has this gist
that contains a single function called
tuple set item
he made tuples mutable because why not
and here's how it works this is this is
absolutely the craziest thing ever we
start with the range which is two to the
16th we create a Python template that
gives you a Python function which is
actually a Python generator you inject
something to the generator some callable
to the generator you call that caller
Bowl and determine if you set a local
variable and you repeat this section of
code two to the 16 times so this is a
function with two to the sixteenth
branches inside you dynamically
construct one of those you take the code
object and then in a while loop and I
love this comment you spray the heap
with generators so what you do is you
find the memory you want to mutate you
start creating Python objects on the
heap until one of them gets close enough
to the object you want to mutate that
you can you can corrupt that array index
and jump to that memory you want to
change notice there is no C code in here
this is all pure Python code once you do
that and once you find one that's close
enough and here's a little thing you
find one that's close enough you pass in
a generator that repeats false up to the
index of the value you want to change so
you inject a generate into that it gets
called so you actually have like a
branch selector here you select the
branch you want
you write the local variable you want
notice here since the co cons does not
actually include that local variable as
part of the frame it jumps out of that
function to the memory you want to
mutate and you manipulate it and the
only risk is you might not be able to
load something close enough to that
function you might run out of memory but
I haven't actually seen that happening
using this code this is amazingly
sophisticated all pure Python and gives
you arbitrary memory access to any C
Python interpreter on any platform
whatsoever so the moment somebody comes
up to you and says look I created a
sandbox in Python you can as long as you
can exact code which you probably can
because actually there's only one exec
here and we can get around it we could
write the bytecode raw so as long as you
can basically import a module I can
break that sandbox using jaws check this
is just remarkably sophisticated I'm so
impressed I hope some of you have a
chance to look at Joe's work it's
amazing so I wanted to share that with
you because I don't think anybody's ever
really looked at this or talked about
this anywhere else thank you
you
[Applause]